J'ai écrit un livre.
J'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelle Votre cerveau est extraordinaire !
Et comme je suis mentaliste,
je sais déjà qu'il y en a qui se disent : "Encore un youtuber qui écrit un livre !"
Bon, bah techniquement, c'est vrai !
Et c'est pourquoi dans cette vidéo,
je vais vous expliquer ce qu'il y a dans ce livre,
pourquoi, quand et comment j'ai écrit le livre,
comment cela se fait que ce livre est interactif,
c'est à dire qu'il communique parfois avec vous,
et à la fin, je vous parlerais des easter egg qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
Y'a des petites choses de cachées.
Génééériiiiique !
Avant de vous parler des trucs un petit peu cool qu'il y a avec le livre,
je vais vous préciser deux trois choses très rapidement.
La première, c'est que le livre est sorti en France, en Belgique, en Suisse, et au Québec.
Amis québécois, il ne sortira que dans 3 semaines chez vous.
Et sinon pour vous le procurer, il est disponible partout,
dans toutes vos librairies,
ce qui est génial parce que cela vous permet aussi de découvrir les librairies de votre quartier si vous ne les connaissez pas
et de voir à quel point les libraires sont passionnants, je vous le recommande.
Et sinon vous le trouverez en ligne, à la Fnac, sur Amazon,
sur tous les sites, je vous mets le lien en description.
Pour vous donner un historique rapide,
ce projet de livre, je l'ai depuis plus de 3 ans.
Et si vous faites le calcul, j'a commencé YouTube depuis un peu plus d'un an.
Le projet initial, il était très simple : c'était de mettre des astuces dans un livre.
Et à l'époque, j'en avais référencé 200, des astuces.
Mais j'avais pas compris que ça ferait un gros livre !
Donc au final, il y en a 50 dans celui-ci,
qui sont illustrées,
et dans une de mes FAQ de l'année dernière, quand on était pas très nombreux sur la chaîne
j'avais dit que oui, j'avais pour projet d'écrire un livre.
"Tu pourrais sortir un livre sur le mentalisme ?"
Ah, ça fait plusieurs fois qu'elle revient, cette question.
Ecoute, je vais vraiment te dire, j'adorerais écrire un livre sur le mentalisme.
J'aimerais beaucoup faire ça, ce n'est pas un projet que je déciderais tout seul,
dans le sens où il faudrait une proposition d'un éditeur
Si tu es éditeur, si vous connaissez un éditeur,
j'aimerais beaucoup mettre ce livre en place.
Et bien suite à ça, il y a un jeune homme qui s'appelle Théophile,
qui je crois a 14 ou 15 ans
qui m'avait contacté pour me donner le contact du père d'un ami à lui,
qui travaillait dans une maison d'édition
et c'est ce qui a fait que j'ai rencontré mon éditrice Aurélie Starckmann
des éditions First au mois d'octobre 2016
et qu'on a lancé ce projet.
Faut savoir que ça a une saveur particulière
J'ai fait plein de trucs cool tout au long de ma vie,
mais avoir un objet, quelque chose qui existe et qui se perpétue dans le temps
c'est très spécial, surtout quand on sait que je suis passionné de livres depuis que je suis petit.
Le goût de la lecture je l'ai eu très tôt
quand ma grande sœur allait à la bibliothèque, quand j'étais petit
pour faire comme elle, j'y allais aussi
et je prenais des livres, mais j'ai toujours au un rapport amical
on peut le dire, avec les livres.
Les livres sont donc mes amis...
Bon, c'est pas des amis bruyants, ça c'est sûr.
J'ai donc travaillé dessus pendant des semaines et des mois
en parallèle déjà de faire une vidéo par jour
et puis après en parallèle de la tournée
c'est d'ailleurs bientôt la fin de la tournée
je vous rappelle que la dernière est à Nantes le 30 juin
Et comme je pouvais pas vous en parler non plus quotidiennement
parce que y'avait pas d'intérêt pour vous
j'ai fait quand même en sorte que ce soit interactif dans l'écriture.
Par exemple un jour, sur Facebook, je vous ai demandé de me donner 5 mots
au hasard
et en fait c'était un défi que je m'étais donné
J'ai pioché un des post avec 5 mots au hasard.
Et je les ai calé dans un chapitre, comme étant une contrainte.
Les 5 mots étaient
Tout ça calé dans le chapitre "Influencer un choix avec des mots"
Après j'ai vraiment fini l'écriture dans les chambres d'hôtel
dans les loges au théâtre, dans les trains
avec Garyzzor et Diablozzor
je leur faisais lire, ils me disaient si c'était bien, pas bien, s'ils comprenaient ou pas en fait
Diablozzor des fois, il comprenait pas
Alors on a rajouté des dessins !
Et je voulais surtout pas écrire un livre du genre "Devenez mentaliste"
parce que c'est pas ça l'objet du truc
La vérité c'est que vous et votre cerveau, vous êtes déjà capables de plein de choses
on l'a vu depuis plus d'un an
y'a 400 vidéos sur cette chaîne
et bien l'idée c'était de synthétiser tout ça et de faire mieux avec ça.
Alors quand j'étais plus jeune,
y'avait un livre qui me passionnait,
c'était le Manuel des Castors Juniors.
BIM ! La référence !
J'ai voulu recréer la même chose d'une manière plus adulte évidemment,
mais à l'intérieur ça donne ça, avec un effet un peu cahier
et c'est pèle-mêle, tout est un petit peu mélangé.
Mais en réalité, j'ai mélangé 7 grands thèmes.
Y'a un index des thèmes à la fin de toute manière,
pour s'y retrouver.
Dans les thèmes, y'a Hypnose et Suggestion
on va dire, tout ce qui concerne les influences.
Y'a aussi le grand thème de la théorie,
la théorie ? On est bien sûrs qu'on a envie de lire de la théorie ?
Y'a que 3 chapitres, mais ils sont essentiels !
Y'a pas mal de chapitres sur le développement de la mémoire
pas mal de chapitres sur le développement du calcul mental
un grand nombre de chapitres sur la lecture non-verbale et la déduction du coup
une dizaine de chapitre sur des expériences bluffantes que vous pouvez reproduire
c'est ce qu'on appelle les "tours", ce que je fais des fois quand je bluffe quelqu'un sur la chaîne
et une partie qu'on savait pas trop comment appeler
on va l'appeler la partie "Développement personnel"
Ooooooooommmmm
Non non ! Ce n'est pas de la méditation.
C'est plutôt sur les rêves lucides, sur la créativité
sur la motivation,
sur le fait de réussir un examen oral.
Tout ce genre de choses qui sont un petit peu inclassables.
Au final c'est un peu construit comme un triangle
c'est-à-dire que si vous connaissez ce que je fais sur YouTube
ou ce que je fais en spectacle
c'est la troisième pointe du triangle
et tout s'associe.
J'ai essayé de garder le même ton,
le même style.
Quand je suis en spectacle, on discute ensemble, on parle ensemble durant 1h40.
Quand je suis dans les vidéos, on échange réellement
que ce soit dans la vidéo, dans les commentaires.
Ou via les énigmes que j'avais mis en place.
Y'a toujours un moyen de se retrouver !
Le livre c'était plus compliqué !
Bah j'ai trouvé quelques idées.
Le livre est interactif !
Parfois le livre va anticiper certaines de vos réactions à la lecture
et j'espère que ça vous fera marrer.
Et à 3 occasions, le livre en lui-même va vous permettre de bluffer quelqu'un.
Je vous raconte une anecdote très courte :
mon éditrice elle m'a dit "Est-ce que tu veux des rabats ou pas pour le livre ?"
bah je me dis "Ça sert à quoi concrètement les rabats ?"
et aujourd'hui ça sert plus à grand chose concrètement.
Bon, on peut écrire des trucs dessus, ça peut servir de marque-page
on peut mettre des choses à l'intérieur
Enfin voilà, c'est un choix.
Et là je me suis dis
"Mais attends ! On peut en faire quelque chose !"
Donc j'ai créé un chapitre où le livre et les rabats du livre vont vous permettre de bluffer quelqu'un.
Une sorte de triangle que vous allez poser entre vous et quelqu'un,
la personne va devoir choisir un symbole ici,
se concentrer sur le deuxième rabat,
et vous allez deviner quel symbole elle avait pensé !
Y'a d'autres choses cachées comme ça qui rendent  encore le livre interactif
mais il y a aussi des choses qui sont réellement cachées
qui sont presque plus destinées à vous
ou à d'autres personnes.
Chacun peut trouver des choses dans ce livre.
Par exemple dans un endroit du livre, il faut que je prenne des noms au hasard
et je parle de 3 personnes, de Pierre, de Lola et de William.
C'est pas un hasard !
Pas plus que le fait qu'ils soient dans cet ordre là précisément.
En fait, dites vous qu'il n'y a pas de hasard dans le livre.
Sauf un ! Y'a une coquille !
Y'a une coquille sur une date, vous la trouverez, je pense que vous la trouverez
vous pourrez me le dire dans les commentaires quand vous l'aurez trouvée.
Il y aura des dédicaces qui s'organiseront
je vous le direz sur Twitter, sur Facebook, Instagram
et sur Snap aussi !
Si vous voulez être tenus au courant, vous m'ajoutez là-dessus,
il y a les liens dans la description.
Et si vous êtes encore là, je vous dis un secret :
je suis allé, dans quelques librairies et quelques Fnac
et j'ai signé les livres, je les ai dédicacés
ça veut dire que si vous trouvez quelque part un livre avec une dédicace à l'intérieur,
c'est une vraie dédicace !
Ça m'a fait rire de faire ça,
j'ai fait ça en achetant moi-même le livre à la Fnac le jour de sa sortie,
et ce livre-là, je l'ai ensuite offert dans la rue
à la première personne qui est venue me dire bonjour !
Voilà ! J'espère qu'une seule chose maintenant, c'est qu'il vous plaira
et qu'il vous servira.
Vous savez, j'ai bien conscience d'un truc :
on était à peu près 50 000, 60 000 sur la chaîne quand ça s'est concrétisé le projet,
et je sais pertinemment, j'ai conscience que c'est parce que vous me suiviez sur la chaîne
qu'ils ont accepté plus facilement ce projet.
La réalisation de ce rêve et la sortie de ce livre, je vous le dois.
Alors merci beaucoup, merci à vous !
Lorsque vous le lirez, n'oubliez pas une chose essentielle !
Pour que l'une de ces 50 astuces fonctionne,
il suffit de vous en servir.
Merci à vous, à très bientôt ! Tchao !